[Music]
nevada state college is celebrating its
largest graduating class with 920
students the institution is seeing more
graduates and enrollments this year
tanya davis is one of those students as
one of the first undergraduate students
to graduate from nsc she went back to
school to receive her master's degree
i'm in my late 40s
it's
i was like there's no way i can do this
because it's pretty you know it's
rigorous professors like dr david kelsey
a founding member of the college's deaf
studies program says it's rewarding to
see students on their big day
i'm really proud of them
they have learned my language my culture
they have immersed themselves in this
and now they're going to graduate and go
out into the world
have a new journey with new experiences
and i look back and reflect now and i am
so incredibly proud of them special
education professor lori navarete says
these past two years have been like no
other and now we're in this economy so
i i see them when they come to class and
when they're in schools doing student
teaching and they're graduating today
they have been so resilient and
graduating students say they are ready
to take on the workforce i know what
it's like to be on that patient side and
then so becoming a nurse and helping out
kids with my disease
is my goal in life i feel like with
nursing there's a lot of opportunities
there's definitely
a lot of different areas you can go into
mary jane vallezza live local now with
around 920 graduating students from
nevada state college this year that's a
100 student increase from last year